the kingdom of Dutch in also called Li
Jian was West ah fangshi and TR XI and
west of a big sea after the frontier of
our Shi you take a boat from the city of
Anjou and cut directly across to hi she
with favourable winds it takes two
months if the winds are slow perhaps a
year if there is no wind perhaps three
years the country that you reach years
west of the sea which is why it is
called hi she there is a river flowing
out of the west of this country and then
there is another big sea the city of Ho
Chi San is in high XI from below this
country you go north to reach the city
of Wudang you then head south west and
cross a river by boat which takes a day
he had Southwest again and again cross a
river by boat which takes another day
there are in all three major cities that
you come to now if you leave the city of
Van Gogh by the overland route you go
north to high bay then West to high she
then turns south to go through the city
of Wu Chi san after crossing a river
which takes a day by boat you circle
around the coast from there six days is
generally enough to cross another big
sea to reach that country
[Music]
this country da chin has more than 400
smaller cities and towns it extends
several thousand Li in all directions
the king's seat of government is close
to the mouth of a river the outer walls
of the city are made of stone this
region has pine trees Cypress Sephora
catalpa bamboo reeds poplars willows
parasol trees and all sorts of plants
the people cultivate the five grains and
they raise horses mules donkeys camels
and silkworms they have a tradition of
amazing conjuring they can produce fire
from their mouths bind and then free
themselves and juggle twelve balls with
extraordinary skill
the ruler of this country is not
permanent when disasters result from
unusual phenomena they unceremoniously
replace him
installing a virtuous man as king and
release the old king who does not dare
show resentment the common people are
tall and virtuous like the Chinese but
where who clothes they say they
originally came from China but left it
they have always wanted to communicate
with China but and she jealous of their
profits would not allow them to pass
through to China the layman can read or
write
who script they have multi-storied
public buildings and private they fly
flags beat drums travel in small
carriages with white roofs and have a
postal service with relay sheds and
postal stations like in the Middle
Kingdom from Anxi you go around high bay
to reach this country the people are
connected to each other every 10 Li
there is a relay shed and every 30 Li
there is a postal station there are no
bandits or thieves but there are fierce
tigers and lions that kill those
traveling on the route if you are not in
a group you cannot get through this
country has installed dozens of minor
kings the Kings administrative capital
is more than 100 Li around they return
the official Department of Archives the
king has five palaces at 10 Li intervals
he goes out at daybreak to one of the
palaces and deals with matters until
sunset and then spends the night there
the next day he goes to another Palace
and in five days makes a complete tour
they have appointed 36 leaders or
who discuss events frequently if one
leader does not show up there is no
discussion when the King goes out for a
walk he always orders a man to follow
him holding a leather bag anyone who has
something to say
throws his or her petition into the bag
when he returns to the palace he
examines them and determines which are
reasonable they use shoe Jing to make
the pillars and table utensils in the
palaces they manufacture bows and arrows
they divide the various branch
principalities of their territory into
small countries such as that of the king
of jisan the king of Lu fen the king of
Qi Ilan the king of Shan do the king of
Sifu and that of the king of U Luo there
are so many other small kingdoms it is
impossible to give details on each one
[Music]
this country produces fine linen they
make gold and silver coins one gold coin
is equal to ten silver coins they have a
fine tapestry woven cloth that is said
to be made from the down of a water
sheep it is called hai she cloth this
country produces the six domestic
animals which are said to all come from
the water it is also said that they not
only use sheep's wool but also bark from
trees or make silk from wild cocoons
they weave woolen carpets finer woollen
rugs felt rugs or curtains all of them
of good quality and with brighter colors
than those made in their countries of
high dong furthermore they regularly
make a profit by obtaining Chinese silk
unraveling it and making who silk damask
s-- that is why this country trades with
Anxi across the middle of the sea the
sea water is bitter and unable to be
drunk which is why it is rare for those
who try to make contact to reach China
the mountains of this country produced
nine colored inferior jade stones they
change color on different occasions from
blue through red yellow white black
green purple rose and dark blue nowadays
nine colored stones of the same type are
found in the evil Shan Duchin has plenty
of gold silver copper iron lead and tin
sacred turtles white horses with
redmayne's white or square lipped
rhinoceroses tortoise shells
black bears dragon's blood and mongooses
large calories giant clams carnelian
southern gold Kingfisher plumes elephant
tusks coloured veined Jade bright moon
pearls night shining pearls genuine
white pearls yellow amber and red coral
they have ten types of glaze or glass
red white black green yellow blue dark
blue light blue rose and purple fine
sonorous trade their gemstone Jade rock
crystal and semi-precious red gems they
have rail gar orpiment blue green
semi-precious stone and multicolored
onyx or jade they have ten types of wool
carpets yellow white black green purple
Rose deep red dark blue golden light
blue and back to yellow finely woven
multicolored wool pile carpets
multicolored and nine colored inferior
quality wool carpets they have gold
threaded embroidery polychrome silk
twill woven gold cloth red or purple
handkerchiefs far lue cloth red or
purple cool cloth handkerchiefs asbestos
cloth fine silk gauze cloth base cloth
do die cloth when Sewell cloth
multicolored towel cloth hangings with
scarlet backgrounds woven with gold and
little round multicolored mosquito nets
all together they have allowed 12 types
of aromatic plants as well as the
overland route from dart Shin through
high bay one can also follow the sea
south along the seven commanderies of
Joshy in contact with foreign people
nearby is a river route which leads to
Jung Chang in Yi province
that's why rare items come from Jung
Chang in early times only the maritime
routes to darchen were discussed because
they did not know that there were
overland routes west of darchen is a sea
west of the sea are rivers west of the
rivers are big mountains running south
to north west of this is the Chi schooi
west of the chi schooi are the Bayou
Shan in the Bayou Sean lives she won mu
west of she won mu are the long Lucia to
the west of the Lea Shah is the kingdom
of - eeeh the kingdom of Jeon Shah the
kingdom of Shu Yao and the Kingdom of
the UAG west of these four kingdoms is
the hey chewy
which is as far west as I have heard of
you one the author observes it is
commonly believed that a fish living in
a little stream does not know the size
of the Yangtze River and the sea the
mayfly for that matter does not know of
the changing of the four seasons
why is this so because one lives in a
small place and the others life is short
I am at the moment intensively examining
dart shin and all the other foreign
kingdoms still it seems to me that I am
neglecting to fully instruct the
uninformed moreover as to the
speculations of Xu yang or the
hypothesis of the diet a chuan alas I am
limited to traveling
by foot and living in the puddle left in
the hoofprint of an ox besides I don't
have the longevity of pang shoe it has
not been my fate to see things firsthand
traveling with the rapid wins or
enlisting Swift horses to view distant
vistas alas I have to strain to see the
three heavenly bodies but oh how my
thoughts fly to the eight foreign
regions
[Music]
you